yang Qian mo da de la ropa la faible masse
de GOI va en taxi dans des cuves sur la acres
bouffée de go PS comprend génial très
cool ne veux pas aussi suda2 beignet XE tu
ne studios pas pour avoir cette belle
combinaison amusante sur la route  votre tête signifie
un grand pour les enfants dont vous savez que
Cheon le secoue accidentellement et c'est
mauvais avec ça ce n'est pas que l'homme alpha a
besoin de marcher ou un immense respect est un non
Sophia ne le préfère pas ici d'abord c'est
votre carte génétique de base  qui fera ou
regardera solo tu mama j'attrape bientôt je peux
voler cet oxygène d'oiseau mais si vous
livrez bientôt l'un des navires au mais
je ne suis pas sûr de ce que vous voulez dire monsieur si
vous remplissez une nouvelle solution une pomme de terre
entreprise qui ne répond pas aux puces
ici, nous allons attendre, je suis Alex, je crois et
je viens d'Espagne et j'ai fait une vidéo pas de
petit homme
ribbit ribbit fait le cookie limité donc
ils vous sont généralement livrés
bien je vais m'en tenir un peu  un peu
maintenant et je ne pense pas qu'une fois que vous aurez
sorti ici la grosse
Fiesta du pitching gaucher  fumer au lit
oui
donc euh la première question était Willa's
Westbourne d'accord eh bien le
jeu d'essais original à l'époque était
basé sur le Web, je pense que c'était peut-être Java ou
flash quelque chose comme ça avant que je travaille
ici mais qui est sorti en 2000 donc  il y a environ
13 ans maintenant d'accord c'était un jeu flash d'
abord définir les anciennes publicités de jeu et
trouver ce jeu bien sûr
oui et maintenant il dit à Joy de développer le
jeu dans une certaine situation d'
accord la première la première version 3d pour
autant que je suis  conscient était charles ii qui
était la dernière version pc oui et puis nous sommes
passés à la xbox pendant un petit
moment nous avons fait de la HD et de l'évolution sur la
xbox ok maintenant nous revenons ok alors
laissez aller comment on fait grâce pour développer un
jeu  comme des essais et combien mais travailler
sur d'
accord bien l'évolution pour la xbox était en
fait en développement depuis assez
longtemps, nous allions pendant je pense
environ deux ans et demi oh oui euh
et c'était une équipe relativement petite pour
environ 40 à  50 personnes
oh d'accord euh mais alors évidemment le st  udio
s'est développé et nous avons en fait obtenu de l'
aide sur Evo Gold pour le PC d'
Ubisoft Shanghai oui donc il y a pas mal de
personnes qui travaillent sur celui-ci et le
temps de développement est d'environ un an d'
accord y a-t-il encore un bébé sous le
jion et combien de personnes  avoir une
résolution de bateau pour vous d'
accord, eh bien, notre communauté est très
très importante, en particulier pour nous car nous
avons l'éditeur de jeu ouais, donc il y a
une énorme communauté autour de cela sur les gens qui
construisent et partagent des pistes d'accord et
puis nous avons aussi juste comme le  les gens
qui sont vraiment durs pour les écrivains qui prennent
les cavaliers ninja ninja nous en avons pas mal
à ce moment-là et ils
sont tellement bons au jeu d'accord c'est un
peu époustouflant parfois à quel
point les gars sont bons mais  pourtant la communauté est énorme
pour nous, nous avons une communauté assez énorme
à ce stade euh au total, nous avons vendu
environ un peu plus d'un million d'exemplaires d'
Evo ou l'exemple est en retard et si vous
comptez le DLC avec Trials HD est vendu sur
deux et  un demi-million de wel  l sur Xbox,
ce sont donc des chiffres assez
importants étant donné qu'il ne s'agit que d'une plate
-forme téléchargeable uniquement oui, ces nutriments
qui sont un PC sont le même jeu que la
version Xbox ou bien avez-vous ajouté
quelque chose d'
ok euh essentiellement des essais Evo gold a
tout le contenu de  Charles évolution
sur la Xbox du contenu original,
mais ce que nous avons également fait, c'est que nous avons également
inclus tout le contenu de charles HD
oui ah mais le Trials HD n'est pas un
peu comme Trials HD et Evo ensemble
comme des jeux séparés quoi
nous avons pris tout le contenu HD et l'avons
recréé à l'aide de l'éditeur d'évolution
afin que vous obteniez toutes les fonctionnalités
les nouvelles fonctionnalités que nous avons introduites dans l'
évolution sont désormais disponibles lorsque
vous roulez sur les pistes HD  ok merci pour
cette interview
pas de problème Luke vois nous avons une base sur
laquelle le W nous avons de la chance Negi do est de tirer
pour visiter El Nadia nous sommes complets vous
devriez reprendre ce module Ciaran Raziel
un membre peut-il préférer utiliser un
autre mot  JE  commencer oublier la banquette arrière
SMB alors qu'est-ce qu'il a eu il n'a pas de SF
Paradiso s'il vous plaît mes chaussures de poney viennent
tranquillement confortable commercial pas cher Ichiro
kamsa ils vont le tuer les
laisser sur l'éducation poopoo haha
pièce de lune d'identité chaque Java Tunisie allée-oop
don '  t taxi away quand un youtuber neutre
Kayla guépard Lilly livre réveil nous avons fait don d'
actions à la zone SMU qu'il y a bien-être
Reggie développeur chef institutionnel
moins cher à faire de Sun bien varié ou une
vidéo vengeance une vidéo spéciale mm vidéo
de Vaca jour d'un singe OST cool off  notre
famille d'ingénieurs 12 marchent il y a
beaucoup de politesse de livre créée la
nature d'un vrai jacuz un bus galant a
également dansé un paquet d'expériences ou la
possibilité de voter Nia concerne SGG
Oprah de plat savoureux aqua donc échantillon de cheveux de dent
petite serviette pour tout comme votre
conversation clignote sur  son réduit de
balançoires à l'arrière à des faits plus électifs
j'étais un prince la pile en fait
nous voyons selca si vos données ne font pas
vraiment pièce
Oh